bonjour à toutes et à tous bienvenue
dans ce nouveau numéro de ski mag 2017
sera l'année et de la mutualisation et
de l'homogénéisation en ce qui concerne
la gestion des déchets à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines collecte et
accès aux déchetteries vont évoluer et
on vous explique tout dans ce numéro
c'est parti
[Musique]
et
en janvier 2016 se formait un nouveau
territoire à 12 les communes transférait
alors la compétence de la gestion des
déchets à l'intercommunalité comme le
stipule la loi notre issue de la réforme
territoriale ainsi qu'une soixantaine de
contrats avec ce transfert est née une
volonté d'harmoniser la collecte et la
valorisation des déchets sur l'ensemble
du territoire tout en gagnant en
efficacité et en cohérence et sans
augmenter la taxe d'enlèvement des
ordures ménagères
pour ce faire un service dédié constitué
de 20 personnes a été créé un service
organisé en trois pôles un pôle collecte
un paul déchetterie un pôle prévention
et valorisation est tout d'abord le pôle
collecte au moment de la collecte
on va voir la gestion des bacs on va
voir les points d'apport volontaire et
l'autre particularité de se suivre ce
que fait le plus nos prestataires et de
l'autre côté répondre aux demandes des
administrés des administrés qui vont
observer un premier changement la
conteneurisation pour maurepas
coignières et les clayes-sous-bois jusqu
alors ces villes avaient une collecte en
sac dans le courant du premier semestre
2010 est les habitants de ces communes
se verront dotés de bacs avec une
poubelle à couvercle jaune pour les
emballages et une poubelle à couvercle
gris pour les ordures ménagères
autre nouveauté autrefois journaux et
emballages été collectés dans des sacs
différents désormais cartons journaux
enveloppa fenêtres et papiers à agrafes
tous ces déchets seront collectés dans
la même poubelle
si ça permet d'éviter un petit peu de
jeux des dessins que tout le temps
tant mieux ça nous fera gagner un petit
peu en développement durable c'est
difficile pour la zone crack peu
glissant pavillonnaire ils n'ont pas de
petits jardins éventuellement va faire m
extérieur
bien sûr qu'ils mesurent appartement que
ça rend est propre
l'endroit pour n'occupe entre autres les
locaux à poubelles
ce sera avantageux ça les prestataires
sepur es d et es nicollin se chargent de
la collecte et pour conserver une réelle
proximité au sein de ce pôle collecte le
territoire a été découpée en quatre
secteurs
chacune de ces zones possède deux
référents de l'intercommunalité a chargé
de secteur et un contrôleur des
collectes leur rôle suivre les
prestataires identifier les réclamations
des administrés ou encore faire face aux
divers travaux susceptibles de perturber
les collègues dédié à ce secteur ces
agents seront répondre plus efficacement
et plus rapidement aux demandes des
saint quentinois
en ce qui concerne la collecte de verre
certaines communes sont en apport
volontaire
d'autres en porte à porte une réflexion
sera menée dans le courant de l'année
afin de rester sur un statu quo ou bien
de choisir d'évoluer vers une
homogénéisation de la collecte pour
toutes les communes du territoire
deuxième pôle les déchetteries elles
sont sept sur le territoire de saint
quentin en yvelines un maillage
développés qui offre des possibilités en
termes de services comme la mise en
réseau de ces pôles de collègues gravats
encombrants bois pile ordinateur
électroménagers ou encore déchets
toxiques les déchetteries permettent aux
habitants de se débarrasser de ces
déchets qui ne peuvent être introduits
dans les conteneurs du quotidien les
différents centres de collecte désormais
géré par l'agglomération ont vu leurs
horaires et jours d'ouverture harmoniser
depuis août dernier afin d'offrir à tous
les saint quentinois un accès généralisé
et depuis le 1er janvier 2016 les
saint-quentinois ont un accès gratuit
sept jours sur sept dans au moins deux
déchetteries de proximité
autre point important pour cette
nouvelle année les sept déchetteries
accepte désormais toutes les mêmes
déchets bonjour la mise en réseau de ces
sept déchetteries nous a permis en fait
d'offrir un service à l'ensemble des 230
mille habitants de l'agglomération
ce qui n'était pas le cas auparavant
vous aviez un certain nombre de communes
qu'ils n'avaient pas accès à ce type de
service et qui n'avaient pour satisfaire
ma demande que accès à des déchetteries
éphémère aux services techniques une
fois par mois notamment pour certaines
communes artisans et commerçants saint
quentinois peuvent aussi effectuer des
dépôts au sein des déchetteries du
territoire
les tarifs pour ces professionnels
seront uniformisées dès juin 2017 sur
chacun de ses pôles de collègues et pour
savoir comment ça fonctionne
petite visite avec une experte nous
sommes sur la déchetterie de magny les
hameaux pas la déchetterie qui date de
si vous avez votre sapin de noël à des à
vous débarrasser ou des gravats du bois
ou de la ferraille vous pouvez aller à
toutes les déchetteries de saint quentin
en yvelines
donc il y en a sept sur le territoire et
vous choisissez celle qui la plus proche
de chez vous ou celle qui est ouverte au
moment où vous voulez vous rendre en
déchetterie donc demain si vous avez des
peintures veille du solvant ou des
produits phytosanitaires
n'hésitez pas à venir les déposants des
faits très peu les végétaux seront
revalorisées en compost la ferraille
redeviendra métal chez les ferrailleurs
le carton sera transformé en matières
premières dans les papeteries les
gravats seront réutilisées pour faire du
remblai dans la benne des encombrants
une partie ira en enfouissement
une autre sera recyclé et une troisième
partie sera incinéré l'amiante les
déchets radioactifs et le goudron sont
par contre formellement interdit en
déchetterie et doivent être transférés
dans des filières de traitement
spécialisés tout comme les déchets liés
aux activités de soins à risques
infectieux les dasri matériaux coupe en
piquant ou tranchant comme les aiguilles
ou les scalpels mais aussi les
traitements anticancéreux ou les
médicaments non utilisés doivent être
scrupuleusement trier le plus souvent
lors de la délivrance de ce type de
produits les pharmaciens dont une petite
boîte jaune dans laquelle la patiente
elle pourra y stocker église et objets
usagés donc une fois que la boîte jaune
est rempli on la referme
puis on la porte à la pharmacie et et à
ce moment là on l'a l'organisme qui
s'appelle le dasri étiez passe
généralement tous les mois pour
collecter ces petites boîtes jaunes
toutes les pharmacies ne sont pas
volontaires pour ce type de service afin
de savoir quelle est la pharmacie la
plus proche de son domicile qui
collectent ces déchets l'usager peut se
rendre sur le site de dasri en 2016 les
sept déchetteries du territoire ont
récolté 18 1350 tonnes de déchets
aujourd'hui deux prestataires se
partagent la gestion de ces centres de
collecte c'est pure sur montigny le
bretonneux et le court plaisir et les
clayes-sous-bois cette dernière
déchetterie devrait passer sous la
responsabilité de veolia
dès le 1er juin prochain veolia propreté
un tout nouveau partenaire pour
l'agglomération depuis le 1er janvier
ce prestataire gère depuis cette
nouvelle année les déchetteries de magny
les hameaux et guyancourt
à deux ou votre mac à moscou pour
pouvoir bénéficier d'un accès illimité
aux sept déchetteries du territoire
les saint quentinois peuvent demander
gratuitement cet autocollant à placer
sur le pare brise
pour cela il suffit de télécharger le
formulaire sur le site de
l'agglomération
de son côté le site au centre de
valorisation des déchets basée à
thiverval grignon se transforme le but
est d'améliorer sa performance
énergétique amélioration du traitement
des fumées remplacement d'une partie des
installations et création d'un circuit
pédagogie de visite
le tout pour un investissement de 113
millions d'euros
le territoire est aujourd'hui deux fois
plus de déchets qu'il ya 40 ans au
quotidien ça représente l'équivalent
d'un kilo de déchets ménagers soit 360
kg par an et par habitant
mais est-ce que les saint quentinois
très correctement leurs déchets je pense
que oui autant sur ce point
si je vous dis carton c'est dans les
jaunes gobelets en plastique dont le
rock de recyclage pots de yaourt
étant donné qu'un déchet dans le général
à poubelles général world of goo
recyclage des kits de refroidissement
alors là je vous avoue que j'en sais
rien au cab axa se portent à la
déchetterie idem pour l'acide
chlorhydrique qui ne doit pas être
abandonnés sur les trottoirs en tout cas
bravo c'est pas mal du tout mais on peut
mieux faire
les taux de refus sont bons ça veut dire
que quand le saint quentinois tri en
général est très bien par contre on voit
qu'on a une marge de progression sur le
tournage à récupérer c'est à dire que
tous les saint quentinois ne trie pas où
on ne trie pas au maximum de ce qu'on
pourrait et donc ça ça va être
effectivement un de nos
futurs objectifs que d'améliorer ce
gisement pour faire du bon tri il y en a
pour qui c'est très aisée tout
simplement parce qu'ils disposent d'un
habitat individuel avec de la place et
d'autres n'ont pas cette même
possibilité et c'est le rôle du
troisième pôle prévention et
valorisation saint-quentin-en-yvelines
souhaite encore améliorer les
possibilités qui s'offrent à chaque
habitant du territoire d'ici peu deux
ambassadeurs du tri sont recrutés pour
faire des saint quentinois des pros du
tri lors d'opérations en porte à porte
d'autres vecteurs doivent être utilisés
afin de sensibiliser les habitants afin
de mieux trier et surtout de limiter les
déchets en amont un vecteur de bonnes
communications pour les ordures
ménagères et pour les déchets ce sont
les enfants les écoles ont beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup plus vrai ces
dernières années pour sensibiliser les
enfants qui eux mêmes sensibilise les
parents et à terme l'agglomération
souhaite optimiser davantage certaines
filières de recyclage meubles usagés
vêtements piles batteries pour une plus
grande maîtrise des coûts et un meilleur
ratio entre tonnages collectés et
valoriser le transfert de la compétence
doit bien effectivement aboutir à des
solutions de traitement et de ramassage
des déchets moins onéreux demain qu'hier
ça c'est une
c'est une volonté mais au-delà de ça il
est important aussi d'avoir une volonté
d'innover et le logo de saint quentin
c'est perdre innovation l'innovation ça
peut également et ça doit aussi se
situer dans les pratiques quotidiennes
je suis persuadé que les
déchets en matière d'innovation sont un
gisement qui peut nous permettre demain
de faire des avancées considérables en
termes d'économie mais aussi en terme
environnemental et aussi en termes
d'organisation et être organisé ça ne
s'improvise pas pour tout savoir sur le
tri ou les collectes pour récupérer
votre badge d'accès en déchetterie ou
remplacez votre bac cassé rendez vous
sur le site de l'agglomération
je vous souhaite une très bonne année à
toutes et à tous trier bien ciao
[Musique]